所沢）⊂⌒~⊃｡Д｡)⊃ ﾄﾞﾃｯ
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ-------------！！！！
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
わぁ!!(ﾟﾛﾟ屮)屮 はい！というわけで
わぁっあっいっ
はい、というわけで
えー(笑)
本日知ったんですけどもぉ！
今日をもちまして！
はじめしゃちょーチャンネル5周年
いえいおっほおっほおっほ
♪ﾊﾟﾁ☆(p´Д｀q)☆ﾊﾟﾁ☆(´pq｀)☆ﾊﾟﾁ♪
＿|￣|○､;'.･　ｵｪｪｪｪｪ
はいこんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです（2回目）ww
なんか今日ですか、8月の…30か。
はじめしゃちょーチャンネルを作ったのが
5年前の8月の30日だったらしくて
まぁ今日で
はじめしゃちょーチャンネルを開設して
5年目…らしいです
♪ﾊﾟﾁ☆(p´Д｀q)☆ﾊﾟﾁ☆(´pq｀)☆ﾊﾟﾁ♪（2回目）
ありがとうございますm(-_-)m
えーホントにここまで
はじめしゃちょーを応援してくださった方
本当にありがとうございますm(＿ ＿)m
⋀,,⋀　 ⋀,,⋀
(　 ・ω)σ)・ω・)
( つ旦 ノ ( つ旦O)
と＿)＿) と＿)＿)
グリッ
まぁいきなりちょっと非常に最近の話をさせていただきますと
とても忙しい(｀^´) ﾄﾞﾔｯ!
なかなかちょっと忙しくてですね
もう実はここ3日間4日間ぐらい
動画撮ってなくて
まぁなかなかこうちょっとゆっくり出来な…
ホントあーうん
質問コーナーも申し訳ない…
質問もね、もうようやく選びぬいてあるんですけども
あとは答えるだけなんで
YouTube始めて
ちょっと最高レベルぐらいに
ちょっと今時間が無くて
頑張って時間を見つけて
必ずやりますので
すまねぇ…
すまねぇ！！！（強調）
ちょっと今は
毎日の投稿より
頑張らなければいけないことがあるので
許してください
っというわけでちょっと
5周年何しようかなと思ったんですけども
まぁ特に無いっす
すみません、明日も朝早いのでちょっと
テキトーにやりますねテキトーに
てかそもそもなんか俺って
テキトーな動画だったと思うんで
今日はちょっと…テキトーに行くね？
んな？
はいというわけでちょっと
今日はとりあえずね、5年間
YouTubeやってみて
ちょっと思ったこととか
感じたこととかねぇまぁいろいろちょっと
軽く話していければと思っております
まぁとりあえず
ホントに、えー
見てくださる皆さんには
感謝しております
いつもありがとう
まぁホントにまず5年間やって思ったことは
まぁ見てくださる皆さんがいてこそのはじめしゃちょーだと思うので
これからも引き続き応援していただければ嬉しいなと思っております
まぁけど…
ねぇ？
最近のYouTube
すごいっすね...(　= =) ﾄｵｲﾒ目
金遣い荒いやなんやもう
めちゃくちゃですよ
なんかね、最近はね、ホントyoutuberっていうもの自体が
凄い有名になってきて
いろんな人も増えて
そりゃあいろんな動画が出てくるんですけど
まぁもうなんかうわ、そういうやっちゃうかみたいな
人のこと言えねぇわ
人のこと言えないようなことも僕もやるんですけども
まぁ他の人、僕から見るとね？
うわぁすげぇなそんな金使っちゃう？みたいな
激しいなーみたいな人もちょっと増えてきてて
まぁ
良いか悪いかで言うと…
どっちでもいいんじゃねぇかなと思います
まぁ僕はもう5年経っても変わらず
まぁ自分のしたいことをしていくだけなので
んー…自分に素直に
僕のやりたいことを忠実に、やっていこうと思います
まぁそれで怒られることもよくあるんですけども
守るべきところは守りつつね？
5年間でもう動画何本作ったっけ？
1400本位ちょっと作ったと思うんですけど
いやーもうねーすごいね
自分で言ったら何なんですけども
なかなかの数を作ってきたなと思っております
まぁあとはなんだろ
特に話すことねぇや
5年間やってみてかぁ
クオリティが上がったと思うな
まぁ僕だけじゃないですよ
僕だけじゃないですけども
基本的になんかyoutuberの作る動画というものの
こうなんか、レベルが上がった
動画の内容も
編集とかも
凄い上がったと思います。僕は
それはまぁいいっちゃいいんですけどぉ
逆に考えるとしょうもない動画出すと、こうなんか
うぃぃぃぃーーーー↷
ってなるんで
もうなんかねぇもうなんかクオリティ高い動画作ればいいやと僕もう思ってたんですけど最近まで
意外とそうでもないなっていう
まぁYouTubeって本来こうなんか
気軽に出せるのが
いいところだったと思うんで
まぁちょっとしょうもない動画とかも必要なんじゃないかなと
ちょっと、この5年間を通して色々考えた末で
たどり着いた答えがそんな感じでした
全然僕よりYouTube長い人とかたくさんいると思うんですけど
まぁ5年間やるって人もそうそういないと思うんで
なるべく毎日出してる人でね？
まぁ5年を迎えて
ここから先もYouTube頑張っていこうと思っていくんですけども
まぁもっともっとクオリティ高いっていう動画ではなく
もっともっと、自分のしたい動画
やってみたいこと
できれば自分らしく頑張っていければいいなと思っております
5年かぁ…
長かったなぁ
所沢…
所沢）痛いよはじめん
はい、というわけでちょっと実はバタバタしています、はじめしゃちょーです
いええええええこわびっくりした
まぁホントね、いろんなyoutuberが増えた。この５年間で
辞めてったyoutuberもいたし
いまだに登録者が少なくても続けているyoutuber、僕は知っています
逆にもういきなりバーッて出てきたyoutuberもいろいろいるんですけども
まぁすごいこう取り巻く環境が目まぐるしく変わっている中でも
まぁ変わらず 撮りたい動画、楽しそうだなって思った動画を撮っていければいいなと思っております
ホントいつも応援してくれるみんなありがとう
今後もよろしくお願いします
とりま！
時間見つけて質問コーナー頑張るわ
じゃあな！
てーてれれれーれーてれれーてれれれーれー
てれれーれーれーれれれれれれれーれー
てってってってっててれれ